ladies and gentlemen my first guest
starred in the hangover movies his
latest film puss and boots
opens friday please welcome zach
[Applause]
[Music]
galifianakis
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
i've been under there for the longest
time did you
didn't hear feel me pinch you during the
reba mcintyre interview
for a week what's wrong with the
traditional entrance pal
i don't like doing that well it's so
good to see you nice to see you too i'm
just gonna try and reassemble this if
you don't mind uh
yeah thank you should i be winded for
trying to break balsa wood
oh that's well that's so much less
impressive now that you said it well you
know
this was pure mahogany you know i will
say you look like you could smash
through anything you i've got to say you
look fit
yeah fit you look like you've been real
i'm a real gym rat
true
if i'm not at gold's i'm either at
equinox or jogging on the beach
really yeah you're just constantly going
at it you're just constantly working
i've always been fit my whole life
real gym rat jim rat you just keep
saying brat
if you say it enough it it it happens so
you think you're a gym rat well
sometimes i consider
myself a gem rat
hi zach how are you good it's nice you
two to get along now
uh we're not more than fine oh good how
about you
you were saying
we've known each other a very long time
and uh used to come on my old late night
show back in the late 50s early 60s and
you would
uh yeah great always had great jokes and
i was thinking today do you remember the
first joke you ever told
uh and when i was trying to be a
stand-up comic uh
yeah i pro i started doing stand-up in
the back of a hamburger restaurant
in times square and the first joke i
ever wrote and performed
was i was with this girl the other night
we were at her house we had been
drinking
and she said zach you can just sleep
here you can sleep on my futon
and i said to her i don't sleep on
anything that rhymes with crouton
that's an actual joke you really haven't
told first joke how did that how does
that really have a joke it's more just a
sentence yeah
i was thinking it's how did that go over
oh it
bombed yeah horribly yeah yeah yeah so
uh
do you ever ever have you ever made the
crouton joke since have you ever gone
back to it i just did
just that was it
12 12 year span i thought maybe you were
dining out on that joke that was a
regular great icebreaker at parties
uh i've got great things to say
ask me to stay over and sleep on a futon
that's the only way it works
[Laughter]
i will say this about you you're not a
overtly political
comic you you're very silly but do you
ever have you ever done a lot of humor
about politics
no i really don't i i i like politics i
i'm a little disappointed i'm a big fan
of uh sarah palin
and um i have been for excuse me
i'm a big fan of parasailing right
totally got confused
so you like parasailing yeah you missed
the futon